yes
[Music]
for optics to home where to
start feel confused with telecommunications
technologies and acronyms
ats lvds lx de 'sale
and copper cable fiber broadband high
speed 7c bandwidth tm ft ch
access networks  of new generation is
enough
in fact it is very simple what
you are really interested in is having a
faster internet to send and
receive songs photos or videos in an
instant make
cheap calls and video calls with family and
friends wherever they are working from
home so  easily as in the office
watch
HDTV shows or TV on demand watch
movies at home play online with your
friends instantly back
up your data online and share it with
family and friends and much more is
proven that  of all technologies
and solutions fiber optics to the
home cph is the fastest and most
reliable way to access the internet what happens
to the  other solutions mobile connections
are much slower than fth,
especially when several users in the
same area share the available
network satellite connections are also
slower than fth they imply a
delay that makes phone conversations
and other
interactive activities difficult other fixed technologies
Like the air
, metal cables up to a hundred times
slower than fiber optics are used to
connect your home to the city's fiber network.
Meanwhile, it can take
an hour to download a high-definition video,
and that's if you're lucky and
no members.  of the family uses the
internet at the same time you have heard your
children complain about this already
with fiber to the home you will have
ultra-fast fiber optics direct to your
home office or building because good
because fiber optics are
flexible strands of glass the thickness of a
light transmitting hair have you
heard of the speed of light that
is exactly what we mean imagine  teach
with fiber to the home you will download a
movie in minutes even if your children
have a video call with grandma
and it will not be obsolete soon because the
17th is a technology of the future and its
capacity is practically unlimited
several million European homes already
enjoy the  fiber optic to the
home waiting for you to connect
[Music]